und das ist wirklich mal ganz blödes
timing ausgerechnet jetzt wo sich die
korona krise schon wieder zuspitzt hat
deutschland keine richtige regierung das
klingt übertrieben das klingt hart aber
im grunde herrscht hier ja nackte
anarchie
ja es ist doch so wir leben gerade im
niemandsland zwischen zwei regierungen
dabei läuft uns im kampf gegen das leos
die zeit davon jeden tag neue rekord
instanzen krankenhäuser längst am limit
die experten der leopoldina fordern
diese woche deswegen zweig bundesweit
und eine impfpflicht für körpernahe
berufe und zwar jetzt besser noch
gestern leider dabei keiner von denen
hier die eier oder den willen das
durchzusetzen so und genau dagegen haben
gestern in köln tausende mutige menschen
protestiert guck mal
gucken wie wütend die sind wie wütend
die sind auf der zülpicher straße zu
recht
warte mal warum sind sie dann verkleidet
und warum sind sie denn besoffen a
gestern war elfter elfter verstehe
verstehe ja die demo hatte gar nichts
mit corona zu tun beziehungsweise sie
wird dann bald mit corona zu tun haben
ich meine gut riesen party
riesen party aber mit 2g kontrollen
heißt es ist bestimmt kein problem da zu
kontrollieren bei den paar leuten was
ist denn hier los nicht nur dass keiner
mehr durchblickt wo im land in welchem
bundesland jetzt 3g gilt oder zweig
plus/minus 4 gm sind die die crux sind
die kontrollen es müsste dann freunde
bitte wenigstens knallhart kontrolliert
werden so wie hier
schwerpunktkontrollen am wochenende
haben laut bezirke zeigt das sind 80
prozent der fälle die gastronomen nur
unzureichend oder gar nicht kontrolliert
haben wir uns entschlossen wir werden
diese auflagen nicht erfüllen das ist
unsere sales wir werden das nicht tun 3g
verordnung die machen wir vom mit wissen
sie warum
gebraut gezapft getrunken
ja ja nichts zu vergessen gestorben
gut viele gastronomen kontrollieren
bestimmt gewissenhaft weil sie ahnen die
alternative ist irgendwann wieder ganz
dicht machen corona kehrt mit macht
zurück und wir haben eine
geschäftsführende kanzlerin die kaum
noch was machen darf und ein kommenden
kanzler der in sachen virus kaum was
machen will es ist mein eindruck ist
sehr gut
ist ein ganz furchtbares tricks band
gestern gestern hat olaf scholz im
bundestag gesagt wir müssten mehr leute
impfen sagt los dann ist 3g am
arbeitsplatz in planung und er sagt wir
sollen irgendwas mit deutschland machen
wir müssen gewissermaßen unser land
winterfest machen jetzt müssen wir unser
land winterfest machen damit wir
deutschland winterfest machen können
winterfest machen immer und bild er fest
index ist das winterfest der volksmusik
[Applaus]
winter habe ich immer gerne geguckt
winterfest total wichtig immer
frostschutz kontrollieren aber apropos
winter irgendwann im letzten sommer hat
die groko ihre impfkampagne
offensichtlich einfach aufgegeben warum
auch immer und die neuen ampeln
maßnahmen nehmen leider wenn sie mal
genau hingucken sehr sehr viel rücksicht
auf ungeimpfte ja ja
bloß nicht anecken alle sollen sich
wohlfühlen in unserer kuschel pandemie
impfpflicht nicht mal in altenheim also
damit wir uns nicht falsch verstehen ich
habe wirklich enorme hochachtung vor
dieser arbeit ich war selber mal wenn
auch unfreiwillig 20 monate in der
altenpflege aber ich meine man geht hat
doch eigentlich rein um menschen zu
helfen
wenn mir das egal ist dass sich die
anstecke keine was anderes machen
irgendwas mit tieren oder möbeln
brasilien also keine frage ohne ironie
freiheitsrechte sind extrem wichtig aber
sie enden grundsätzlich da wo ich die
freiheit von anderen gefährde oder ihr
leben es ist echt traurig meine mit
einer besseren impfquote hätten alle
wieder ihre freiheit stattdessen wird
kurven diesen november zwei jahre alt
und zu genau dem thema begrüße ich jetzt
das corona virus jan abend zweiter
geburtstag
feiern sie das eigentlich
ich war gestern schon im kölner karneval
unterwegs alter schwede war ein geiler
abend war kolonie ich fühle mich
überhaupt wahnsinnig wohl bei euch in
deutschland wollte ich einfach mal
loswerden ja das hört man gern ehrlich
jetzt ohne scheiß in anderen ländern wie
ich behandelt werde unterste schublade
italien da sind fast alle geimpft
spanien auch und ja man komplett
digitales gesundheitssystem so kann ich
nicht arbeiten
da lob ich mir gut
ihr habt nicht meine regierung
daran trage jetzt die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft und drehte in die fdp
ein
deutschland deutschland
[Applaus]
sagen sie mal haben sie gerade für
corona geklatscht geht es dann ja jetzt
heißt es schon wieder wenn wir mit 2g 3g
und den ganzen anderen geht es nicht
bald die wende schaffen bleibt nur das
sogenannte notschalter lockdown für alle
mit anderen worten schön mit öl
weihnachten ja gut dafür
dafür kommen aber jetzt die kostenlosen
test zurück die übrigens und das ist mir
ganz wichtig gar nicht kostenlos sind
die zahlen wir alle man könnte auch
sagen ich zahle die tests von xavier
naidoo ja mache ich gerne aber noch
lieber würde ich ihm die impfung zahlen
aber es ist eine andere geschichte genau
das gleiche höhe und hat bei der
schulpolitik maske auf fenster zu maske
wieder runter bei den kindern fenster
auf wirklich die schüler in deutschland
können einem nur noch leid tun ich würde
mir wünschen dass die politiker jetzt
gerade weil die zahlen jetzt wieder
wieder hoch schießen dass wenn die zahl
zu werden sie wirklich mal drüber
nachdenken viel entweder wieder die
masken pflicht einzuführen oder wenn es
viel zu hoch ist auch wieder die schulen
zu schließen und die präsenzpflicht
wenigstens auszusetzen
so konnte ich mich mal mit 30 ausdrücken
ein erschreckend eloquent das mädchen in
einer berliner grundschule
erkennt den ernst der lage ihr vorschlag
da wir ja im moment keine
bundesregierung haben wie wäre es
stattdessen mit einem krisenstab aus
grundschülern
so leute mit schreiben und vor zwei ging
zwar bundesweit falls einzelnen länder
nicht mitmacht schicken wie die
bundeswehr außerdem sind nicht für peru
von
jobs ging das nicht passt der kann ist
der ablegen
weihnachten fällt auf pressemitteilung
gilt zuvor traf cola krise beendet als
ich hab so drauf
hochschüler
ich meine klar
keine frage werden sich jetzt auch
geimpfte wieder öfter testen müssen und
ab einem bestimmten alter viel schneller
boostern aber der blick auf die
landkarte lügt nicht je niedriger die
impfquote in einer region desto voller
die intensivstation punkt ende der
debatte geimpfte versus ungeimpfte
einriss der mitten durch freundeskreise
und familien geht haben sie vielleicht
gelesen der spiegel dazu gerade einen
großen fast schon herz zerreißen artikel
gebracht es ist wirklich heftig was
dieses corona mit deutschen ehen macht
die königs ein normales er bis zu diesem
verhängnisvollen momentan schätzt kennst
eigentlich dieses telegramm das habe ich
mir gerade mal runtergeladen ist echt
ganz interessant die katzen im toten
verändert sich über nacht seine dna klar
wegen das protein die ganzen koppel die
werden alle versteckt in der
kanalisation
[Musik]
die auf der intensiv liegend sind kämpft
und in der stadt stefan kühne erkennt
seine frau ramona gar nicht wieder ich
erkenne meine frau ramona gar nicht
wieder sie hat sich in den letzten 20
sekunden in einen völlig anderen
menschen verwandelt
da im einzelfall immer mehr deutsche
paare entfremden sich in der pandemie
ich wollte erst nicht wahrhaben aber
dann habe ich zufällig gehört was sie
unserem kleinen voll ist und am ende
sind alle erwachsenen an biontech
gestorben auch mama und papa und die
kinder waren ganz allein
und dann der horror moment ich gucke so
ins wohnzimmer und sehe meine frau tanzt
zu nehmen
[Musik]
da
stefan kühne versucht es zunächst
geduldig mit argumenten aber
eine weitere ehe zerbricht an corona
doch dann hat stefan kühne die rettende
idee ist da ganz einfach ich habe jetzt
hier im wohnzimmer meine eigene zweig
zone cool oder
und einmal mehr hat die liebe gesiegt
[Applaus]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbol ihr bei uns im neuen studio
gefunden illuminati freimaurer
staatsführung ist alles dabei dann
wollen wir denn die eigentlichen
strippenzieher bekannt geben
dass so viele abonnenten auf youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten